my name is pat kinsell i'm the founder
and ceo of notarize i've been obsessed
with building an enduring technology
company my entire life i started my
career at microsoft i left and built a
search business that i sold to twitter
and really by total chance i went to get
a document notarized for that twitter
transaction and a notary screwed it up
they stamped it but forgot to sign it
and that was really the you've got to be
kidding me moment that i had in my life
this critical transaction that got
messed up and it set me down the path
and so i researched all 50 state laws
you know designed a product to comply
with you know what i thought were the
regulations at the time and have been
advocating for notarize ever since
my entire life been searching for one
boring idea that has incredible impact
and so when i stumbled upon notarize
really in the first week of our
existence we got calls from some of the
largest industries in america who said
if you think it's a pain to get
something notarized imagine managing
that process tens of thousands of times
or hundreds of thousands of times a year
and so notarize is a company that really
has been
pulled forward by our customers and the
demand for it when notarized went live
we were a three-person company and so it
was very much you know everyone having
to do everything i was up all night
you know manning the support cues
answering people's questions we were
very fortunate as a company to come out
and really have an impact large banks
and enterprises contacting us really
with two conflicting messages some
people said this is the greatest thing
i've ever heard this changes everything
about the way we run our business or
serve our customers and other people
frankly had incredible concerns about
the legality and effectiveness of the
service
you really want to change something what
really matters to your customers is if
it's safe and effective and accomplishes
what they need and really try to help
people understand that we're taking a
legacy solution and bridging it into the
digital era you know not three months
after we had launched there was a task
force of key regulators you know we got
on planes we went out and met with
countless regulators across the country
and we said we have nothing to sell you
we just want to explain how this works
and how it's effective
and so hundreds if not thousands of
flights later you know we've now passed
39 state laws and won countless
approvals and i always encourage
entrepreneurs to engage
one of the
ways that we were successful in changing
legislation was comparing our service to
the paper alternative i think oftentimes
when people try to design a digital
solution
they go sort of to the theater of the
absurd and if you really take a step
back and you ask yourself the problems
that a notarization is trying to solve
is to ensure the person's properly
identified and that there's an
independent record of the transaction
after the fact and the tools that we
have in the world today are so much more
effective than holding up a driver's
license and scribbling in a book you
know notarizations are really a solution
to prevent fraud there's been studies in
the paper world of notaries you know
when you hold up an id getting it wrong
as much as 30 percent of the time and so
it notarized we bring all of the tools
and all of the solutions of the modern
era to ensure people are identified and
these transactions can be verified after
the fact
i want my legacy to build something that
stands the test of time that has real
enduring impact i say to the team at
notarize all the time we may not have
the financial reward that you know
everyone dreams of but we are the people
who have made it possible to buy a home
on the internet sell a car online and no
one can ever take that from us
you